كثيرون لديهم وفره في الاحلام وللاسف ندره
في الامكانيات وفقره وفره ايضا في الامال
وندره في الاموال لذا احنا بحاجه دائما في
كثير من الاحيان لماذا يعادل للقروض
مختلفه متنوعه القرض الشخصي بالتحديد يخفي
الكثير من التفاصيل التي يجب ان نعرفها
طبعا وعلى عكس اي قرض اخر لا يتم تامين
القرض الشخصي مقابل
رهن او اصل بل مقابل راتبك وسمعتك الماليه
كيف تاخذ هذه القروض وعلى اي اساس تدرس
خطواتك وهل من عواقب لذلك
[موسيقى]
اللي رشوا عود انا وانا بحب
معنا الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو السمره
المشط الصحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد صباح الخير
صباح الخير ومن العطور هلا بدنا ننتقل
للقروض يعني
القرود الشخصيه
مبدئيا اول قروض بشكل عام والفائده عليها
وكيف ممكن انه ناخذ يعني افضل قرض بالنسبه
لنا بالبدايه اول شيء هناك طبعا الفرق
يعني بين القرض اللي تاخذه عاديه من البنك
وفيه الكريدي خلينا نتكلم مثل ما تكلمنا
سابق مدفوعات الاقل
طبعا اعلى فيعني اذا تقدر تاخذ اذا تريد
تاخذ 25,000 درهم او ريال لنفترض فمن
الافضل انه تاخذها قرض عما انه تاخذها
كريدت كارد لانه الكريدت كارديل في اغلب
الاحيان حتكون الفائده
99% على الكريدت كارد دائما اعد الفائده
القروض تكون عليها مثل
الفيدرالي يعني مثلا ممكن تكون خمسه
بالمئه خمسه وربع بالميه حاليا بعد ما تم
رفع الفائده مؤخرا
الكريدت كارد يعني خصوصا اذا تاخرنا
بالدفعات وعليها ممكن يعني تتعدل عشرين في
المئه الفائده على
سمر سعر الفائده وهذا اللي يدوخنا دائما
رافعين الفائده وارتفع سعر
شلون اقدر اني انا اعرف الفلاترك او انه
سعر الفائده هذا واقدر اني احدد واخذ على
هذا السعر ما ادفع اول شيء تابعنا على
الاسواق العربيه
يا جماعه ثاني شيء دائما هناك فائده هناك
قروض بفائده متحركه تتغير
يعني حسب الوضع الاقتصادي هي السوق هناك
فائده ثابته لازم نشوف الاخبار انجنيرت
يعني هاي الفتره خلال سنتين الماضيه كان
دائما في عندنا رفع لاسعار الفائده فكان
من الافضل انه ناخذ قرض بفائده ث لا ننسى
القروض ايضا مثلا عندك او الرهن العقاري
طبعا في حال انت ما دفعت القرض اللي عليك
هناك عقوبات يعني ممكن يتم يضع البنك
ايده على البيت هناك قروض ناخذها كنت
سالتيني انه شلون نختار لازم نقارن اكثر
من مو بس بنك من هناك جهات اخرى تعطي قروض
يكون شويه الفائده عليها اعلى فلازم دائما
نقارن بين جهات مختلفه لازم نقرا بنود
العقد نقرا اذا احنا دفعنا حتى اذا دفعت
قبل القرض هم عليك بانيل تدفع زايد اذا
تاخرت تدفع سداد مبكر اذا تاخرت ايضا هناك
عليك بناتي في بعض الدول اذا انت ما مسدده
القرض اللي عليك تمنعين من الخروج من
الدوله وبصير او يعني سمعه ماليه سيئه
هلا ما بين مثلا الاختيار ما بين انه اخذ
قرض بفائده منخفضه اول سنه وبعدين ممكن
تتغير وتكون مثبته لمده سنه او سنتين
بتكون فائده منخفضه ولا الافضل اني اخد
قرض بفائده متوسطه ولكن ثابته لمده خمس
سنوات يعتمد على الظروف الاقتصاديه اليوم
احنا اذا نتابع الاخبار نعرف ان هناك
المزيد من رفع الفائده ربما مره او مرتين
بعد حتى نهايه العام بسبب الظروف
الاقتصاديه حتى يتم كبح جباح التضخم يعني
اعتقد هسه احنا اذا وصلنا الى نهايه رفع
الفائده فالان من الافضل انه واحد ياخذ
فائده متغيره بس الان المشكله بعدها
اسعارها جدا عاليه
يمكن اذا انتظرنا اذا نقدر ننتظر للسنه
القادمه حيرجع يتم تخفيض الفائده مره اخرى
ممكن هذا الشي يعني طبعا نتاثر حسب
بمليون وعندك تدفع بيت اكيد
ماخذها على سياره لا يعني ما راح تفرح
اصلا مليون درهم يعني بطل يجيب بيت حطه
صغيره
عم ترتفع حلقه مليون درهم وين تجيبلك شخصه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات